we made some choices last cycle that
ended up not being the right choice
using the unfortunate reality of it was
you know it fell short of where we
really wanted it to be so I'm 15
reinvested we doubled down we built a
custom scanning rigged with an array of
12 DSLR cameras we kind of defined what
our needs were in terms of this scanner
had to be easy to use how to be portable
because in the past it's just been way
too cost-prohibitive for us to actually
create the volume of high-quality assets
and so because of the old way we used to
work that's why a lot of our likenesses
would fall short with NBA live 14 in
order for an artist to go ahead and use
any available photo reference that we
have it would take them approximately
six days to create a likeness now we get
an automated result in 45 minutes it's
really cut our time spend down but at
the same time exponentially increased
our quality as we started seeing the
results coming out of those scans we
started to quickly realize wow that
stuff's looking good how many things can
we actually get in front of this scanner
i mean we started scanning uniforms and
to be able to pull wrinkles and
stitching and other details out of i
couldn't be happier with with the look
of the game and it is right now and the
best part about it is is we still have
some time to go and i know we're going
to get even better than what we've got